[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Judy, that was exquisite.
Thank you so much.
Thank you all for being
here, and thanks especially
to my Radcliffe fellow Fellows
and to the Radcliffe staff that
have humored me when I
said, could we possibly
make it a more inviting space?
So it's really an
honor to be here,
and I'm going to start
by saying, forgive me.
[LAUGHTER]
Forgive me if I miss the
mark or otherwise disappoint.
Think about that phrase.
Forgive me.
How often have you said it?
These are the words that
we use when we arrive late,
when we need someone to
repeat a phrase that we
didn't hear well, when we do
something much more egregious.
These are the words that are
familiar in the prayers of so
many religions.
These words are steps towards
repentance and redemption.
Is forgiveness between
people something
so worthwhile that government,
courts, legislatures, juries,
public officials
ought to encourage it?
Should law itself be forgiving?
Forgiveness as I
use it means letting
go of justified
resentment or grievance.
The justified part
is pretty important.
It's not forgiveness
if there's a defense,
if there's an excuse,
if there's a ground
to blame the other one.
Requests for
forgiveness fill art,
including lyrics of pop
culture, detailing mistakes
and apologies between lovers,
parents and children, citizens
and governments,
individuals and their gods.
Victor Hugo's classic novel
Les Miserables-- who's read it?
Who's seen the show?
OK.
The story illuminates the human
costs of an unforgiving law.
It imposes those costs not
only on the criminal defendant,
but also on the law enforcer.
In its climax-- spoiler alert--
the escaped convict,
Valjean, mercifully
spares the life of the police
chief who has spent years
pursuing him, shocking
the man of the law
with the power of forgiveness.
Whether to forgive and why
is a theme in entertainment,
in relationship advice,
in religious counseling
and political drama.
And when a high
government official
is caught in a personal
or political scandal,
journalists and philosophers and
bloggers and family and friends
discuss whether and when such
a figure should be forgiven,
and if so, by whom.
Forgiveness expresses
a generosity of spirit
and a constructive
focus on the future.
It's potentially a
non-depleting resource offering
physical, psychological, and
practical relief for wrongdoers
and for victims of wrongdoing.
And it's not just for people.
One thing that I've been able
to do during my Radcliffe
fellowship is read about
how animals strengthen
their social relationships
through acts of consolation
and attentiveness, often
taking the forms of grooming
and stroking and sexual conduct.
Not exactly what
people do all the time.
But it reduces tension and
strengthens community and peace
and social integration.
And maybe, maybe
biological evolution
developed forgiveness
as a survival tactic.
But forgiveness has its limits.
Mass murders, rapes, abduction
of children, genocide.
Some acts defy conception,
not to mention forgiveness.
In these circumstances,
private or public pressure
on a victim to forgive looks
like a new victimization,
denying the victim
her own choice.
Pressure to forgive
unfairly targets some people
more than others.
Some people may not
feel very forgiving.
And I know about that
because I drive in Boston.
[LAUGHTER]
It's even harder to figure
out whether and when law
itself forgives.
Can a government forgive
on behalf of its citizens?
If courts or prosecutors forego
warranted legal consequences
for instances of
wrongdoing, does that
jeopardize adherence to
rules, to deterrence,
and the commitment to
treat like cases alike?
My work asks whether and
when law should encourage
people to forgive one another.
Should law itself
be used to encourage
people to forgive each other?
And should law itself forgive?
I am focused on criminal law,
both in the United States
and internationally.
And internationally, that
means crimes against humanity
or other very serious offenses.
And I'm also focused on debt.
It may seem like
an odd conjunction,
but think about it.
It's not by accident.
We talk about forgiving a debt.
And in my efforts, I'm looking
at consumer debt, debt produced
by the legal system itself
like fines and fees,
and sovereign debt,
debt incurred by states
and municipalities and nations.
Also of interest
everywhere I look
I see questions of forgiveness.
Should the government forgive
violations of immigration law?
Are there limits on the
pardon power of the president?
Will the growing use
of algorithms in law
permit more forgiveness
or restrict it?
Now lawyers like to focus
on particular cases.
This gives us context.
It also means that we actually
realize at the end of the day,
there has to be a
practical decision.
Let me share with
you a tough one.
Like many legal problems,
it has disturbing elements.
It involves a killing of a
person with disabilities.
It presents troubling
legal and moral questions.
And warning, I'm going to
ask you your views very soon.
Louis Repouille, an
immigrant to this country,
sought to become a
naturalized citizen.
The governing law then and now
requires that such applicants
demonstrate, and I
quote from the statute,
"good moral character.
Good moral character
during the five years
preceding the application."
Unfortunately, four
years and 49 weeks
before his application,
Mr. Repouille
engaged in an act that led to
his prosecution for murder.
What was the act?
He used a drug to put to death
one of his five children.
The child was then 13 years
old, had severe brain damage,
was blind, unable to
communicate or control
his bodily functions,
feed himself, or move.
Mr. Repouille was
indicted for manslaughter
in the first degree.
That means that the
prosecutor viewed it
as a serious offense, but
less serious than murder
or first-degree homicide.
He was charged with the crime
of killing a person when there
are mitigating circumstances.
A jury agreed and disagreed.
The jury convicted
him of manslaughter
in the second degree, which
means a killing reflecting
recklessness or negligence
rather than an intention
to murder.
Not exactly suited
to the circumstance.
The jury did something very
unusual even beyond that.
The jury wrote the judge a
note and said to the judge,
please use the utmost clemency.
The judge in turn stayed
the sentence, which means
suspended any punishment,
and placed Mr. Repouille
on probation, which he served.
And that was the end
of the criminal case.
Four years and 49 weeks
after he killed his son,
Mr. Repouille applied to
become a United States citizen.
And now we come to the
question, what would you do?
If presented with
his application
to become a United
States citizen,
how should we view what happened
in light of the legal standard
requiring the applicant to
prove "good moral character"
in the prior five years?
Yes or no?
"Good moral character,"
enough to become
a naturalized citizen, and why?
OK.
I'm going to ask you to talk
to your neighbors about this.
At least one other person, no
more than three others, OK?
All right.
Are we ready?
What did you think?
I mean, actually, there's
several questions here, right?
So what did you think?
And you can tell
me what you think
the questions are too, right?
What do you think?
Well, and what's
the right answer?
But you can also
frame the question.
Liz.
- I was going to say, the
law doesn't say legal.
It says moral.
- Correct.
- And so one then would be
making a judgement about what
the moral situation was.
And clearly, the jury was
making the recommendation
based on a definition
of morality
that they felt that
they [INAUDIBLE]
have been [INAUDIBLE]
moral choice, right?
Moral choice.
- So you would say, go ahead
and grant him citizenship.
OK.
Yes?
- Is it more or less horrible
because the child had brain
damage, as opposed to
someone in a [INAUDIBLE]??
- Right.
That's a tough question.
- Did he-- this is my
husband's question.
[LAUGHTER]
Did he turn himself in
and say, I did this.
I know it's against the
law, but please have mercy.
Or did he try to conceal
his killing of a child?
- OK.
Good question.
- I have a question.
What was his intent
for killing his child?
Was it really that he felt
it was a mercy killing,
or was he just
sick of the burden?
- Right.
OK.
So people want to know more.
Michael.
- Was it actually requested
by the child in whatever
form he could communicate?
- This child could not
communicate in any way.
That one, I know the answer to.
- Can we please wait
for the microphone?
- Oh, mic is coming to you.
Sorry, sorry.
- No.
I asked the question,
cultural context.
So his actions in
a different culture
may have been
considered ethically OK.
- Such a great question.
And after all,
he's an immigrant.
And so by which country's
standards should he be judged?
- Sorry.
What did the mother think?
- What did the mother think?
It's a good question.
And one more.
- Besides the circumstances
of his killing,
the question before
us is whether he
should get citizenship.
And considering
how many citizens
we have that are wingnuts
and running around, killing
people on a daily basis--
[LAUGHTER]
--a weekly basis, apparently.
You know, it's hard to draw
the line on the citizenship
question here.
So to me, besides what
we might interpret
into the case about the
condition of that child,
the citizenship
question is separate,
and I have no problem
granting him citizenship.
- And should the morality
be tethered to the average
of existing citizens?
Or should it be something
quite different, right?
Yeah.
- I'd also say, with respect
to the legal, moral component,
the jury, what they convicted
him of implied no malintent
in that it was negligent
as opposed to first-degree
manslaughter, which
is malintent oriented.
So that also probably plays
into the moral-- you know,
I don't know if we
can use the conviction
as a standard of his
moral conduct in that
what he was convicted of has
no moral component to it.
- Great.
- Does it matter?
And I would think it does
of, what was the method?
I mean, he didn't do
something cruelly.
He didn't have a machete.
- Chloroform.
- OK.
So it was a painless death,
as far as we would know.
- As far as know.
That's right.
- I would like to know what
else he did during the five
years, not just this one issue.
And secondly, to
really think about
whether good moral character
is merely the absence of bad.
- These are deep questions.
Look at this.
[INAUDIBLE]
- The way you framed the
question is, what would you do?
And I would not let
him in the country,
because I think that this is
so beautiful as a discussion,
but there's so many people
who want to gain entrance
to the US, and you gave
us such an extreme case,
which is very ambiguous.
I think it's a
very clear answer.
- OK, great.
Lisa.
- I think it's also a
very fundamental question
about the nature of criminality
and whether the occurrence
of a criminal offense is likely
to indicate that there will
be criminal behavior
in the future,
whether there is almost a notion
of a propensity to immorality
that is indicated by
a previous offense.
- Great.
Great.
We obviously could
spend the entire time
talking about this case.
It's a very fascinating
and hard case,
and you have done better
than the court did.
The appeals court
didn't know what to do.
I really want to
tell you, this is
one of the most puzzling
decisions I've ever read.
I think we have before us
so many wonderful questions
that you've asked, and at
least one set of questions
is what, if any, role should
that prior criminal case have
in interpreting the standard
for the immigration case?
Another question is, what
is good moral character?
And even behind that,
how would we know it?
Is it philosophic?
Is it sociological?
And of course, would you
grant the citizenship or not?
So I can tell you
that what actually
happened, if that's of
interest-- is that of interest?
Yes.
So the case first
went to a trial
court, the federal district
court, which said, yes.
He has demonstrated
good moral character
and ordered that he be
granted citizenship.
Very much, as Liz
suggested, in looking
at what the prior jury had
done and what the judge had
done in that case.
The district attorney
appealed the case,
and it went to the Court of
Appeals for the Second Circuit
where three judges
clearly disagreed
with each other over what
was good moral character,
over whether courts could
answer it, and over what to do.
And I'm going to read to you
from the majority opinion.
"Left at large as
we are without means
of verifying our conclusion
and without authority
to substitute our
individual beliefs,
the outcome must
needs be tentative."
[LAUGHTER]
It gets worse.
"And not much is
gained by discussion."
The court basically said,
this case is too hard.
We can't decide.
And then because
it was unclear--
this is where lawyers have ways
to deal with things like this--
he loses.
Because it's not
clear, he has failed
to persuade the court
that he demonstrated
good moral character for
the prior five years.
It was his burden
to persuade us.
But the appeals court goes on.
They say, but three weeks can
go by, and he can file again.
[LAUGHTER]
Then the conduct falls
outside the five-year period.
What are we to make of this?
It's authored by a distinguished
judge with a very curious name.
The name is Learned Hand.
[LAUGHTER]
Can you imagine being
in elementary school
with that name?
Anyway, the court did not
forgive the lawyer's mistake
in filing the petition
three weeks earlier.
Clearly, this was a mistake
by the lawyer, right?
The court was not
forgiving about that, OK?
Point one.
However, the court offered
forgiveness in saying,
file again.
Without prejudice,
the court specifically
said, allowing it
to be filed again.
The dictionary actually
defines forgiveness
as allowing for a
degree of imperfection.
This is allowing
for imperfection.
So yes, the majority on the
court, two out of three,
were forgiving in dismissing
the case without prejudice
and allowing a new
petition to come.
The statute itself
is kind of forgiving.
Five years.
Why does the inquiry
stop at that point?
Practically, there's
a kind of, we
have to make the
fact finding not too
difficult for the government.
But I think there's also
an implicit, whatever
you did five years ago,
you're a different person
in the meantime.
And yet, I have to
say, I wonder what
a court would have done if
the person applying even
had waited five years
after committing genocide?
Would the court then say,
we're not going to look at it?
Aren't some acts unforgivable?
And to know what's
unforgivable, let's
start by looking hard
at what forgiveness is.
And then what does legal
systems and rules currently do
to seek or promote forgiveness?
So by forgiveness, as
I've already indicated,
I mean a conscious,
deliberate decision
to forego rightful grounds
for grievance and resentment
against those who've
committed a wrong or a harm.
A grievance is a
justified complaint.
And I have to say, the
notion of resentment
has resonated with me
right now, because I
don't feel very forgiving
at this moment in the world.
But there are a lot
of resentments flowing
in lots of
directions, and it has
made me feel even
more how important it
is to try to find ways to
relieve the resentments that
have occupied us in this
country and in others.
Forgiveness can offer
benefits to an offender.
It can relieve a
sense of isolation.
It can offer solace
and acceptance.
It can benefit even the
victim, because letting
go of resentment is
a huge liberation.
Even for some, regaining a
connection or simply feeling
empowered by the
choice to forgive.
But to forgive cannot
be an obligation. .
It has to be a choice held
by the one who was harmed.
And declining to forgive
itself is empowering.
It's a way of saying, no.
I have one thing left, which
is the ability to forgive,
and I'm not going to.
It may be a way to
demand accountability.
Some people may find it
impossible to forgive
if the wrongdoer
has not apologized.
This came up in the discussion.
What has the wrongdoer done in
the meantime, or made amends?
And even when a
wrongdoer apologizes,
a wrong has been
done, and the desire
for consequences, even the
desire for revenge I think
should be honored.
I think that's the source
of a sense of justice.
It's only when you have a
sense that I have been wronged
is there a view that actually,
there is a better way,
and I am entitled to more.
A wrong should be made right.
An intended harm should
be met with a consequence.
Pursuing rights,
correcting wrongs.
This is the heartland of law.
And crucially, some
acts are unforgivable.
But then the legal system
itself often forgives.
It creates time limits
on consequences.
It creates amnesty provisions.
It creates other devices.
And here's a danger.
The even-handedness of the
law may be jeopardized.
With each act of forgiveness,
what about another case?
Is that going to be
treated the same,
or is that going to be
treated differently?
And courts and
legislatures, at their best,
speak to our highest
hopes for fairness,
for predictability,
equality, freedom
from bias and corruption.
And exceptions can
really mess that up.
On the other hand,
let's be honest.
Forgiveness is built in
to any legal system that
is run by human beings.
There's the discretion of
police, prosecutors, judges,
juries.
They exercise their discretion
sometimes to let people off
without punishment.
Governors and presidents
issue pardons.
Courts reduce liabilities.
Bankruptcy proceedings negotiate
reduced payments on debt.
Legal discretion
permits flexibility,
and it also permits bias.
Racial bias, other biases.
Unpredictability, a
lack of transparency,
all at odds with the ideals
of fairness and equality.
So what to do?
Well, it would be nice
to say I have an answer,
but I have a year
to figure it out.
What I do believe is that
law should serve human ends,
and the purposes of law
should be our purposes.
They're not some abstract
thing up in the sky.
They're not a rulebook with
a set of answers somewhere.
And we should use
law to help convert
suffering into opportunities.
Those opportunities can
prompt forgiveness perhaps
by individuals, or
inject forgiveness
inside the operation
of law itself.
So let's look a little
bit more closely
at how forgiveness
already operates,
at least in the
American legal system.
And that's a step
towards considering
when it should be used,
when it should be promoted,
when it should be restricted.
So legal institutions
and political actors
can promote forgiveness
by individuals,
but also promote it.
But also discourage
it, I'm sorry.
And law can itself
enact forgiveness
by foregoing consequences
for wrongdoing.
Here are six examples.
People who borrow too
much money to pay back
can informally seek forgiveness
from the creditor, the lender.
Or they can file for bankruptcy.
That's otherwise known
as a fresh start.
It's much desired by people
in debt because of credit card
expenses.
It's much desired by cities
and sovereign nations that
are swamped with debt.
And student loans come to mind.
As I worked on this
subject last year
as the dean of a law school,
student loans came to mind.
Right now, Puerto Rico is
very much in my thoughts.
Puerto Rico does not
have the legal authority
to declare bankruptcy,
because it's not a state,
and it's not authorized
by the Congress to do so.
That's one reason they are
in such terrible shape.
And their struggle
to convince creditors
to restructure loan
payments and secure
extended time and actual
forgiveness, obviously
compounded by recent hurricanes
and a difficult economy,
currently $70 billion in debt.
So can there be some
mechanisms beyond bankruptcy?
Second example.
Law can treat a doctor's
apology to a patient
as an admission of mistake,
exposing the doctor
to malpractice liability.
Taking a different
tact, 36 states,
including Massachusetts,
have an apology law
which prohibits the
admission in trial
of expressions of
sympathy or apology
by a medical practitioner.
Only lawyers would call
that an apology law,
but it's an apology law.
It just exempts this language
from any subsequent trials.
What the states adopting
this law want to do
is they want to remove
the disincentive
to have the normal human
interaction of an apology
and to encourage communication,
a release maybe of resentment,
grants of forgiveness maybe by
patients or a patient's family.
This law, by the way,
is very much supported
by the medical profession,
because those states that
have it actually have a reduced
rate of malpractice cases.
Third example.
Courts can require spouses
on the brink of a divorce
to try to mediate
their disputes.
A good mediator will
call upon each spouse
to express their grievances and
desires of the other person.
And even if they then
go on and divorce,
the spouses can become
more understanding,
more cooperative,
maybe even more
forgiving when they've tried to
see the world through the eyes
of the other person.
I know a mediator who regularly
sets the very first session
with a divorcing couple at
a terrible, terrible time,
and then watches
with kind of a smile
as these fighting spouses
agree that the worst
person in the world
is the mediator who
set this terrible time.
[LAUGHTER]
A fourth example.
Legal officials can ask a victim
of a physical assault whether
or not to prosecute.
A victim who chooses
not to proceed strongly
affects whether or not the
law is going to forgive,
whether or not the law
is going to give up.
Some states in the context
of domestic violence
have adopted what are called
no-drop rules, laws that
treat the assault as a
violation of public norms
and requiring the prosecutor
to go ahead, regardless
of what the victim thinks.
You can probably imagine why.
Here's the problem.
A victim can
decline to prosecute
not because of forgiveness,
but because of fear.
And so these laws are efforts to
try to take the responsibility
out of the hands of the victim.
And yet, the victim
can, of course,
come back into the process
at the sentencing time
to offer forgiveness
or its opposite.
Fifth example, pardons.
Executive power to
pardon an individual who
is charged with or
convicted of a crime
is a power that was
held by kings, still is,
and by government officials who
think of themselves that way.
[LAUGHTER]
Judicial processes can also
operate in a kind of pardon.
So you can move to have
a criminal record sealed
or to have it expunged so
that there's no record.
No one can get it.
That's a kind of pardon,
at least a limited pardon.
And amnesties created
by statute or by treaty
can eliminate or reduce
the negative effects
of criminal charges or any
other kind of legal violation.
Governments can also consider
barring consideration
of a conviction, a
criminal conviction,
in other settings like
in an employment setting.
Sixth example, I
mentioned amnesty.
Amnesty, I think, it's
a whole other category.
It can be used to bar
civil suits as well
as criminal suits.
It can be used with
conditions on testimony
or after a civil war with rebels
surrendering their armaments
or providing reparations
or showing remorse.
President Ronald Reagan in 1986
enacted an immigration law.
It was dubbed Reagan's
amnesty, somewhat in the news
these days, permitting
about three million people
in the country who
were here unlawfully
to gain legal status.
It was an amnesty.
Amnesties can follow
armed conflicts
when nations may decide
not to have criminal trials
or to address violations
of human rights.
And part of the peace process
in Colombia right now,
human rights activists who've
been charged with rebellion
have received amnesty,
permitting both freedom
and opportunity to
apply for employment
and go on with their lives.
Similar proposal is pending
right now in Uganda,
and many people
see this as a way
to move on, to get
out of the mess,
while others criticize
amnesties because people
who may have committed
seriously violent crimes
go without legal consequences.
And I just want to
underscore this.
This is the heart
of forgiveness.
It means letting go when
there's justification to punish.
It's not forgiveness if
that quality is lacking.
Novelist Doris
Lessing once said,
"If you understand something,
you don't forgive it.
You are the thing itself.
Forgiveness is for what
you don't understand."
In that context,
I think it's worth
having a little bit more
extended discussion of probably
the best example of
amnesty in recent memory,
and it's South Africa's Truth
and Reconciliation Commission.
How many are familiar with that?
Most people are.
Great.
So it's over 20 years ago on the
road to the peaceful transition
from apartheid to its
current democracy.
The Truth and
Reconciliation Commission
was adopted at the end of
the negotiation process
for the interim constitution.
It was a word invented
by the negotiators.
Instead of a prelude, it
was a postlude, or something
like that.
A postamble.
A postamble to the constitution,
that there will be a process.
And then the legislature
enacted this process.
Over three years
of its operation,
the TRC, as it's called, invited
victims to tell their stories,
and invited perpetrators to
apply individually for amnesty,
conditioned on showing
how their actions were
limited to and proportional
to political motivations.
It granted ultimately
849 amnesties out
of 7,112 that were filed.
And victims offered testimony.
The designers hoped
that this process
would prevent cycles
of revenge and create
public acknowledgment
and a shared history.
Its chair, Archbishop Desmond
Tutu, reflected on his work
and said, "Forgiveness
means abandoning your right
to pay back that
perpetrator in his own coin,
but it is a loss that
liberates the victim."
It has inspired a lot of
debate and discussion.
As it proceeded, the political
cartoonist [? Zappo ?]
vividly demonstrated the
problem with the Truth
and Reconciliation
Commission by showing
Archbishop Tutu standing
in a cartoon on ground that
was labeled truth, and
then there's a chasm.
On the other side
was reconciliation.
Once you know the truth, it
may be even harder to forgive.
And I think importantly, the
TRC was criticized by people
on all sides of the conflict.
Studies show ambivalence,
disappointment, mixed reviews.
And one study indicates that
very few people individually
forgave.
Only seven people in
the study of about 500
said that they forgave.
And yet even with its
flaws, it provided
a kind of ritual, a marker,
a way, perhaps, to move on.
I think we won't
know how actually
to evaluate the TRC
until we know more
about South Africa's future.
It has, in the meantime,
inspired efforts
all over the world.
There are over 40 Truth and
Reconciliation Commissions
in other countries
following conflict.
And it's also inspired a field.
Academic studies have exploded.
I've asked myself,
why such emulation?
And I can't separate it out
from the leadership offered
by Archbishop Tutu and Nelson
Mandela, inspiring narratives
and images to communities
thirsty for hope,
particularly following violence.
It offers a kind of third way,
I think, between no response
to atrocities and
costly or controversial
criminal prosecutions,
on the other hand.
In the United States,
truth commissions
have occurred in
Mississippi following
racially motivated crimes in
Greensboro, North Carolina,
following the murder of
anti-KKK, Ku Klux Klan
organizers.
And in Maine,
investigating the abuse
of Native American children
by child welfare agencies.
I have questions.
I have questions about
truth commissions.
I have questions
about forgiveness.
Consider the woman whose husband
was imprisoned and tortured
during the apartheid era
in South Africa and said
to the TRC, and I quote her,
"A commission or a government
cannot forgive.
Perhaps only I could do it,
but I am not ready to forgive."
When a government
says, we forgive
on behalf of the people, who
is the government to do that?
The government doesn't
have actually the authority
to forgive.
So what the government can do
is the government can forego
punishment, but that's
not actually forgiving
in the interpersonal way.
I asked the commissioners
of the South Africa Truth
and Reconciliation
Commission, as they
were holding their hearings,
about why didn't they
make the amnesties
conditional on apology?
It's like the question that
came up in our discussion.
And they gave me an answer
that has haunted me ever since.
They said, they decided not
to make amnesty conditional
on the offer of apology
because they said,
then we could never know
if any apology is genuine.
I thought that was
really insightful.
And that's a window onto the
difficulties of using law
in this area, because there are
consequences and there's power.
And therefore, if you're
trying to actually nurture
human communications,
you distort it.
And yet, and yet, one of the
staff members of the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission
brought together informally
the mothers of young men who
are known as the Guguletu 7 who
were killed by the secret
police when a government
informant said, these
are revolutionaries.
They're going to
do something bad.
The informant came to the
TRC and applied for amnesty,
and the mothers were separately
giving their own testimony
as victims.
And the psychologist,
Pumla Gobodo-Madikezela,
brought them all
together, and just
thought they ought to meet.
The informant, a South African.
The mothers, black
South Africans.
And it happens to be captured
in a film, a documentary film,
which I highly recommend called
Long Night's Journey Into Day.
The mothers begin
the conversation
by yelling at this informant and
saying, how could you do this?
How could you turn
in your brothers?
How could you take away
our sons, our children?
They chastise him,
and he hangs his head.
He apologizes.
And then one by one, each
of the mothers forgives him.
It's hard to understand.
It's an informal setting.
It's not compelled by the law,
not formally organized by law.
It's moving.
I think it would be very
troubling if it were compelled.
And here's a troubling fact.
30% of the participants in
the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission reported feeling
pressure to forgive.
If you're in the presence
of Archbishop Tutu,
you might feel
pressure to forgive.
I think many of us
remember in 2015
in this country, an
extraordinary, memorable public
demonstration or forgiveness
as some of the family
members of the nine people
killed at the Mother Emanuel
AME Church in Charleston,
South Carolina
offered forgiveness to
the shooter, Dylann Roof.
Anybody remember this?
Other family members
expressed condemnation.
One said she hoped that
he would go to hell.
Roof has remained unrepentant
about firing 77 shots.
Came back to mind with
the terrible events
of this past weekend.
He said at his bond
hearing that he
intended to start a race war.
Some members of the
families of victims
described how they were
working on forgiving him.
And others said that
they forgave him,
but that did not mean he
should avoid punishment.
The daughter of
murdered Ethel Lance
said, "I will never
talk to her again.
I will never hold her again.
You hurt me.
You hurt a lot of people.
But God forgives you,
and I forgive you."
It's a mystery.
It reflects a kind of
disciplined religious practice.
Another surviving
relative explained,
we have no room for hating,
so we have to forgive.
Now some people watching
this have now said,
this is how white people set the
terms for acceptable grieving
by blacks.
This is a longtime
structure that
deflects anger that's justified
and treats systemic violations
as if they're occasional.
Philosopher Myisha
Cherry criticizes calls
by journalists, particularly
upon black victims
of white violence
or state violence,
to forgive because
the requests are
disrespectful of the victims.
They normalize oppression.
They underscore
racialized roles.
She says, are white victims
ever asked to forgive this way?
Others warn that there's a
gender dimension of forgiveness
that raises cautions about
using law to encourage it
or to induce it.
Studies suggest that women
are better at forgiving.
Why is that exactly?
Is it that women
have had to forgive?
Studies of history
and literary analyses
of supplication and apology.
Western culture often connects
women with forgiveness,
and expectations that women
will perform emotional labor
in society grants
authority to men often
in ways that contribute
to pressures on women
to forgive and to
ask for forgiveness.
And in this light, using law
to promote forgiveness risks
reinforcing already
existing hierarchies--
race, gender,
differential power--
in ways that put unfair
pressure on people's emotions.
And on the other hand--
I'm running out of
hands-- on the other hand,
some people, due to their
religious tradition,
their personal beliefs,
view forgiveness
as a worthy aspiration.
And by forgiving, they
express their own faith.
So I'm running out of hands.
I do think it can be emotionally
draining not to forgive,
and I do think it's a mistake
to imagine that law has
no impact on people's
emotions, even
with no forgiveness
as part of it.
Law can push people
towards adversariness.
So it seems to me
not wrong to ask,
can law make space for
forgiveness, but how to do that
without putting pressure?
That seems a real challenge.
But I'd separate that out.
One question, therefore,
is when should law
make space for
individuals to engage
in apology and forgiveness?
From the question
when law itself
should forego the consequences
of wrongful action.
And I do think on that one, we
should be pushing much more.
We're living, at least
in the United States,
in a period of the
most incarceration
in the history of the planet.
There has never been a society
with as many people criminally
convicted and incarcerated.
I think forgiveness would be
a good thing for the system
to inject, and I'd say
the same thing about debt.
The amount of
debt, and I'm going
to talk about both
of those things.
I think that we can make some
progress on the big question
that I have, which
is, does it undermine
respect for the rule of law
to have more forgiveness
by having less
adherence to the rules
as they're written
down by talking
about concrete examples?
And my two are child soldiers
with some general thoughts
then about juveniles
and criminal law,
and then debt with
sovereign debt and consumer
debt as the examples.
And I'll be relatively
brief about both,
because I really hope we can
have time to talk together.
So child soldiers.
International criminal law has
made a big advance recently.
First time in human
history, there
is a crime recognized of
turning a child into a soldier.
This was actually the subject
of the very first case
before the International
Criminal Court.
And Thomas Lubanga, the
warlord in the Congo,
was convicted of this crime.
First time ever recognized.
Interesting.
Convicted for 14 years.
Compare that with criminal
sentences in the United States.
How, though, should the
children themselves be treated?
When children are
abducted or coerced
or enticed into assuming
the role of a soldier,
they're victimized by adults
who take away their childhood
and make them instruments of
law, [INAUDIBLE],, and violence.
But some join without
being abducted or coerced,
and some are drawn by the
ideology or the opportunities
for action, responsibility, the
thrill of committing violence,
the cause.
Some who join under coercion
later engage in terrible acts.
They kill people,
they rape people.
Some stay for decades,
well past their childhood.
Should their exercise
of any degree of choice
make them culpable, or
should they be forgiven?
International law has created
a problem for us in this area.
Every country in the world
except the United States
has signed the Convention
on the Rights of the Child.
Every country except
the United States.
I mean, every country
but the United States
says that anyone
under the age of 16
should not be tried
for any war crime
or crime against humanity.
So an adult can be charged with
turning a child into a soldier.
A child under the age
of 15 cannot be tried.
But 15 and 16-year-olds,
17-year-olds, they
are not liable anywhere.
And here's a problem.
In many societies,
they're adults.
And there's a problem
about reintegration
often when they return home,
and what should happen?
So legal theorists
would say, forgiveness
is not even the right concept
if we're talking about minors.
They're presumed to
lack the intention,
the knowledge,
the control that's
necessary for criminal
responsibility.
And certainly, this
makes sense if you're
talking about a three-year-old.
But anybody here ever
talked to a 15-year-old?
They have some capacities that
make them a little bit more
like adults than the
three-year-old. .
One adolescent soldier
explained to a researcher
that he planned to return
to Liberia so he could claim
the benefits available to
demobilize child soldiers
and then return to the fighting.
Some children in armed
conflicts demonstrate
choice in their involvement.
And some find ways to
actually escape and come
back and escape and come back.
It's a complicated story.
And I have wondered whether we
do a service to these 15, 16,
17-year-olds by saying,
you are innocent,
and no one's going
to ever talk to you
about what happened here.
We'll give you job training.
Researchers who
work in this field
have informed me
more that I have
that for many of
the child soldiers,
the real challenge
is self-forgiveness.
And Emmanuel Jal, who's a
former child soldier who's
become a very successful
musician and rapper,
has said this himself
in his lyrics.
He says, "I'm in another war.
This time, it's my
soul I'm fighting for."
And so I'm wondering if it's
possible to imagine developing
something like a
Truth Commission
where people who've
been child soldiers
have an opportunity
to tell their story
and not be punished.
But yes, explore the
ways in which they
had some responsibility or not.
And nations and the
international community
could create a public
process for people
who participated in armed
conflicts before they were 18.
And maybe in doing
so, the young people
can not only help themselves,
but help their societies.
As I've thought about
this, I've thought, boy.
This would be a good thing for
our juvenile justice system
to explore.
Our juvenile justice system
started in 1899 with the idea
that young people shouldn't
be treated the same as adults.
There should be a
more forgiving place.
Over time, it has
become, if anything,
more onerous than the criminal
justice system for adults.
And indeed, across
the country during the
get tough on crime
period from the '80s on,
there is now automatic transfer
of juveniles to adult court.
Juveniles are regularly
put in adult prisons.
It is a pretty
disturbing situation
for those who end up there.
It is a likelihood
they will never, never
return to a path of success.
So many communities
are exploring
what's called restorative
justice, the development
of opportunities for the
victims and perpetrators
to talk together, for wrongdoers
to provide services, repair,
repaint houses,
engage in restitution.
Hate crime examples where
individuals are actually
invited to come and
speak in schools.
And there might well be
opportunities for something
like a Truth Commission also
to give these young people
a chance to explain,
what was going
on in their community that
made this conduct seem
like the right thing to do?
Just a thought.
I do think, of course,
once you go down this road,
you start thinking,
what about adult?
Why have this cutoff
for people under 18?
I think that's not a bad thought
to be having and exploring.
So my second example,
forgiving debt.
The concept of debt infuses
Western and Christian morality,
and it's not by accident that
we use the word forgiveness
in The Lord's Prayer and in
bankruptcy, restructuring debt.
And like spiritual
forgiveness, bankruptcy
represents the chance
to start fresh.
In 1789, before becoming
the third president
of the new nation,
Thomas Jefferson
argued to his friend
James Madison for relief
of each generation's debt.
Maybe because Thomas Jefferson
was in debt over and over
again, he really thought about
this a lot, and he worried.
Because he was Thomas
Jefferson, he developed it
into a political theory.
And he worried that one
generation should not
burden the next with its debts.
And well aware of the debts
incurred by the colonies
en route to becoming a nation,
he argued that with respect
to future debts,
would it not be wise
and just for the
nation to declare
in the Constitution
there forming
that neither the legislature nor
the nation itself can validly
contract more debt than they
can pay within their own age
or within 34 years?
His friend James
Madison said, you
have got to be out of your mind.
This would jeopardize
law, private property.
We can't do this.
And despite that
argument, the Constitution
of the United States--
read it some time--
actually guarantees that there
will be a right of bankruptcy.
And in the business
world, this has
been perhaps one of the keys
to the story of innovation
in the United States,
because declaring bankruptcy
is often viewed as a
cost of doing business,
and there's not much
shame involved in it.
Individuals another story.
The individual still
undergoes shame
and personal difficulties,
and some of that
has to do with the loss.
Some of it has to
do with society.
Big Apple Circus.
Anybody see the news today?
It's back a year after
declaring bankruptcy.
It can be a lifeline for
businesses and families,
even though it can be difficult.
And cities.
Detroit, Michigan.
Jefferson County, Alaska.
San Bernardino, California.
Stockton, California.
Each have declared
bankruptcy, and each is doing
much, much better financially.
But some debts lie
outside of bankruptcy.
In the United States currently,
student loans cannot be
discharged in bankruptcy except
in the instance of death.
Isn't that generous?
[LAUGHTER]
So think about this.
In the United States,
for-profit companies
that create student loans
to target for-profit schools
can declare bankruptcy.
But the students cannot
declare bankruptcy.
Sovereign nations are another
group that cannot declare
bankruptcy, and their debts
can be forgiven by creditor
nations, private lenders, but
it is very difficult to organize
that.
And only severe
crises that threaten
to spill over into the region
pushed the European finance
ministers to help
Greece reduce its debt
and extend its
schedule of payments.
And while defaulting
on debt can seriously
damage a nation's credit
ratings and its access
to capital, larger financial
trends and improved
domestic governance, pragmatic
attitudes about the future
mean that Argentina
of all countries,
which has been one of
the most indebted nations
in the last 200 years,
just successfully floated
a 100-year bond.
Had no trouble selling it.
So it is possible to
have a fresh start,
even after something
very difficult.
I'm really interested in
how the Pope and Bono have
made this a cause.
They are using the biblical
notion of jubilee year
to clear a state of
all of its debts,
and advocating for
the forgiveness
of the debt of the
world's poorest countries.
And they've made some progress
on a multilateral debt relief
initiative.
Philanthropic efforts
in the United States
have taken a page from the
practices of commercial debt
companies.
You know, the
secondary debt market,
they buy debt for pennies
on the dollar, right?
That's what the companies do,
and then they go after people
and they garnish their
wages, and so forth.
So philanthropies now are
buying consumer debt and student
debt and medical debt
and forgiving it.
I think that's a
pretty good charity.
One group started during
Occupy Wall Street
calling itself Rolling Jubilee.
It raised $700,000
for four years,
and it used it to
buy $30 million
of debt, which it forgave.
I think that the government
could promote that.
The government could create
tax incentives for people
to do that.
There could be other ways to
make this kind of forgiveness
more available,
and that would be
true for municipal debt,
consumer debt, and so forth.
So I'm going to close.
I want to say that implicit
in my discussion there
is another question, which is
some wrongs are unforgivable.
What are those wrongs?
Philosopher Hannah Arendt
claimed that we cannot forgive
absolute evils that are too
large and too radical punish.
Others say that's exactly
when you need to forgive.
I find it a really hard
question, as Judy said.
This is a kind of sequel
to a book I wrote before.
And people have
asked, ever since I
wrote a book called Between
Vengeance and Forgiveness,
well, why not forgiveness?
So that's what I'm
struggling with.
I do think that a focus
on forgiveness in the law
will help us expose
the imbalance
of the current practices.
So for example, we have a
doctrine called harmless error
in criminal law.
Guess who gets to claim it?
The government.
Criminal defendants never
get to claim harmless error.
Or another imbalance,
during the subprime crisis,
banks were allowed
forgiveness for not
being able to have
their paperwork,
but the consumer
was not allowed.
I think a focus on forgiveness
could be very helpful,
and it might actually help
us specify the circumstances
under when it should be
promoted, when it should not.
A group of social scientists
asked Latin Americans
and Western Europeans
about forgiveness,
and found that a majority
of people in both regions
favor forgiveness, even
without a change of heart
or an apology, anything on
the part of the violator.
But interestingly,
those in Latin America
were more likely than
those in Western Europe
to accept as the
forgiver someone
other than the offended person.
So this issue I said before,
that the government cannot
forgive, that may be
culturally specific too,
and worth thinking about.
I think we have to guard against
turning to forgiveness solely
when more robust justice
is not available.
And we should be careful
not to use the law
to distort private emotions
or to undermine the commitment
to treat similar cases alike.
And yet, I think we should
consider how and when law
can usefully make space for
forgiveness or forgive itself.
I've been thinking
about Mr. Repouille.
I think he deserved
consequences for his actions.
But how striking it was
that the jury and the judge,
all the judges thought
some forgiveness was due.
There's a man named Paul Boese.
I don't know who he
is or was, but he
loved to craft sayings
that would be quoted.
He wrote before Twitter,
but he would have loved it.
And now he'd have
double the letter space.
Here's one of his quotations.
I like it so much I'm
going to end with it.
He said, "Forgiveness
does not change the past,
but it does enlarge the future."
Ultimately, forgiveness points
towards the future, not just
the past, and I think it
offers an important dimension
for designers and
agents of the law.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]